I'm Charles Payne I'm Kat temp I'm
Stuart Vonnie and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday March 15 2023 I'm Jessica
Rosenthal the official and unofficial
Republican Presidential hopefuls are
highlighting education related reforms
on the campaign Trail pulling a page
perhaps from one Governor's Playbook as
he pushes lawmakers in his state to back
his agenda we have to be focused we
don't lose an entire generation of
students to this learning loss and I
think we I think we can make great
Headway partnering with parents with
teachers and school systems and making
sure that students have the resources
that they deserve I'm Chris Foster today
arguments in a Texas Federal courtroom
over whether abortion pills should be
legal One Drug in particular they
believe that the FDA rushed this through
the the clinical trials are are not safe
they they say it's not a safe medicine
and they're using the idea that the
Supreme Court overturned uh the right to
an abortion and I'm Tommy lahren I've
got the final word on the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
as Republicans head to Iowa testing the
2024 presidential Waters in the state to
hold the first nominating contest one
topic keeps coming up education Iowa
recently passed a school choice Bill
setting up education savings accounts
with taxpayer dollars that allow parents
to send kids to different schools former
president Trump who has said he's
running again was in Davenport Iowa this
week with a speech on what he called
America First education policy I said
the other day I will bring back parental
rights into a school system right please
and the place went crazy Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis has not officially
announced a run but was in Iowa anyway
and spoke in Des Moines saying parents
should have more say over the kind of
books and content in classrooms and
that's why we've done things like ban
critical race Theory from our K-12
schools we're not teaching kids to hate
our country or to hate each other with
your tax dollars uh no way South
Carolina Senator Tim Scott has not yet
announced if he's running yet but was in
Iowa a few weeks ago and toured a
Catholic school with Iowa's Governor
commending her school choice Bill
parents you do not pay property taxes so
that adults with agendas can tell your
kids that there are a hundred genders
but only one ideology and while not in
Iowa South Carolina's former Governor
Nikki Haley who has announced she's
running spoke about education from New
Hampshire saying new laws like the one
in Florida restricting gender and sexual
orientation conversations to those in
fourth grade and above aren't strict
enough we should not be talking to kids
in elementary school about gender period
And if you are going to talk to kids
about it you need to get the parents
permission to do that the issue has
ramped up in Congress as well with
Republicans introducing a parent's Bill
of Rights law while Republican
Presidential hopefuls make education
related reforms a critical part of their
campaigns they may be taking at least in
part from The Playbook of Virginia's
Republican Governor he made education
specifically parental involvement a
Cornerstone of his 2021 campaign but
it's been an uphill battle Democrats in
the state legislature have blocked parts
of that agenda like bills that would
have eliminated so-called critical race
theory in K-12 schools and one that
would require kids to participate on
sports teams according to to the gender
they were born with another bill that
failed would have made it easier to
create Charter Schools as did one that
would have put the state on a path
towards school choice with education
savings accounts though some things were
passed through executive order there's
still a lot to do but I must say that I
am extremely encouraged by all that
we've gotten done over the course of
last 13 14 months Glenn Younkin is
Virginia's Republican Governor you know
when we came in we were hired to put
forth and move on an agenda that would
re-establish parents at the head of the
table raise expectations and standards
in our schools introduce Innovation make
sure that decisive Concepts critical
race Theory and other teaching
methodologies were removed from our
schools and to re-establish trust
because trust had been lost by parents
Republicans and Democrats and what was
going on in in a lot of Virginia schools
particularly in Loudoun County and I'm
very pleased by the progress that we've
made through a combination of bills that
have been passed on a bipartisan basis
and executive action and I think we're
going to continue to use all the tools
in our toolkit in order to drive forward
with all of the elements of that same
agenda and we've still got a ton of work
to do to re-establish Virginia's
educational standards as the best in the
nation in previous administrations had
watered them down and lowered them to
the worst in the nation after Virginia
had been a destination for people to
move here to get access to our K-12
schools and our and our great
institutions of Higher Learning and
we're going to get Virginia back there
quickly we've got a ton of work to do to
drive forth our Innovation agenda our
lab schools came out of the box strong
we've now authorized 13 planning grants
in just over seven months of work I'm
very excited about the fact that we're
going to have specialized schools
that'll allow students to pursue paths
in health care in Aerospace and the
skilled trades to go to work right after
high school if they choose to do that uh
and we've continued we have to continue
to work on providing more options for
parents our tax-driven scholarship
programs are really important and we
will continue to support that and I do
believe over time that we can come
together on providing more and more
choice for families so we've got a lot
to do I'm excited about it we also
continue to see constant pressure on a
day-to-day basis where Northern Virginia
school systems like Fairfax County
specifically did not inform parents that
their children had received a National
Merit Commendation right and that was
systematically done I've pushed back
hard we saw School recently offer
college prep classes only to Black and
Hispanic students and that's just not
right it violates the Civil Rights Act
and and so this is also just constant
work day to day because these school
systems particularly in in our Northern
Virginia area had really embraced this
constant pursuit of equity over
Excellence It's been a Health that they
wanted to make sure that every student
had equal outcomes for all students at
any cost
well the reality is we need to allow
students to rise and run as fast as they
can and we can raise the ceiling and the
floor and that's what education is all
about so this is not a anywhere near a a
uh a done project for us it is a
constant effort to make Virginia schools
the best in the nation I understand also
you did not get those tax cuts those
additional tax cuts through this year
um again that was stopped by the the
Democrats as you focus on education
especially the learning loss and this
effort to pay teachers more as well as
put money millions of dollars towards
tutoring as well as easing teacher
requirements to transfer into Virginia I
wonder if you don't get your tax cuts
through the legislature might you pitch
spending that money on those education
policies on the money you do want to
spend on on education
with our legislative session in fact our
budget negotiations are ongoing and as
part of those negotiations I fully
intend to to get tax cuts Virginia is
running another Surplus 3.6 billion
dollar uh expected Surplus that's on top
of a four billion dollar tax cut package
last year and Virginians are being
overtaxed and there is plenty of money
to give money back to Virginians it's
their money not governments and I fully
intend to do that and we can on top of
that continue to fund education
initiatives you know we had the largest
education budget in the history of
Virginia last year that included 10 pay
raises for teachers investments in
facilities and investments in Innovation
like our lab school initiative and we're
going to continue to press forward on
those kinds of very very important
Investments including as you rightly
point out initiatives to close the
learning loss Gap and we launched this
week 30 million dollars of micro grants
that are available available to Virginia
families specifically customized to
their children in order to provide
opportunities to close the learning loss
you know we were we were heartbroken if
not devastated to see that so many of
the policies of the past in addition to
the extended and unnecessary closure of
our schools resulted in Virginia kids
experiencing the largest learning loss
in the nation and so we went to work
right away with with free tutoring
Partnerships with the Khan Academy a
real focus on bringing more teachers
back and money to recruit but this
microgrant initiative is really
important because it provides families
the ability to customize the kinds of
support that their student needs in
order to catch back up we have to be
focused that we don't lose an entire
generation of students to this learning
loss and I think we I think we can make
great Headway partnering with parents
with teachers and school systems and
making sure that students have the
resources that they deserve Governor um
pivoting here because you've got more on
your plate than just education right I
am understand Democrats in your state
say your decision to say no to this Ford
EV battery facility is costing
Virginians jobs and they accuse you of
only doing this as a political move can
you share with us more about your
decision to say no to a Ford plant that
is in business with the I guess a
Chinese supplier of electric vehicle
batteries I guess Ford is taking this
now then to Michigan
yeah the entire uh suggestion that this
is anything political is silly uh the
reality of course is that we see uh in
this case Ford Motor Company partnered
with a company called cattle which is
influenced if not controlled by the
Chinese Communist Party their behavior
has demonstrated it their CEO is on the
top industrial Planning Commission of
the Communist party and all that Ford is
doing here is setting up what what I
think is a trojan horse relationship to
allow this Chinese Communist party
controlled company to gain access to
incentives from taxpayers and it's not
it's not right the the the inflation
reduction act incentives were put in
place to create trusted Supply chains
American Supply chains or Supply chains
uh that rely on trusted partners and it
specifically excludes Bad actors and yet
here's a circumstance that was put
together in order to circumvent that
rule I think it's wrong and when invited
to propose an incentive package from
Virginia I chose not to I think the
reality is that China has one goal the
Chinese Communist party wants to
dominate the world at America's expense
and we have to recognize this and we in
Virginia are doing are doing everything
we can in order to stand up we've passed
bipartisan legislation that prohibits
the purchase of our Farmland by Bad
actors I ban Tick Tock and WeChat for
all government devices and then
legislation followed immediately and of
course we continue to see the Chinese
Communist Party trying to invade our
education institutions with recent
Revelations that they had been donating
to our top high school to gain access to
curriculum and methodology in the Thomas
Jefferson School of Science and
Technology we must recognize as As
Americans that the Chinese Communist
Party the Chinese government is not a
friendly competitor they are trying to
to win at all costs and using every
element at their disposal from
surveillance with balloons to economic
coercion and imperialism around the
world and in the United States and into
military saber rattling we've got to
stand up and be strong and as Governor
that's that's what I plan on doing and
if there's another project and you find
out that there's a relationship with
China that sounds like any project that
comes before you with any relationship
to China would get next it wouldn't move
forward in Virginia well let's just be
clear that this is not a wholesale a
condemnation of Chinese people
it's a recognition that the Chinese
Communist party that is the Chinese
government has a plan right and in this
case particularly this company is not
just influenced but it really does
appear to be controlled by the Chinese
Communist party and that is a very very
important recognition we also need to
recognize that there are industries that
we we're going to have to have extra
scrutiny upon semiconductors the supply
chains for electric vehicles and and
solar panels and wind turbines our
telecommunications infrastructure
Pharmaceuticals I mean there is a long
list of national strategic imperatives
around these industries that we have to
pay attention to and I do believe that
our our that the Biden Administration is
weak on this topic they need to be far
more insightful and need to stand up
stronger against the Chinese Communist
party and and I encourage them to do so
briefly um I I know you're we have to
run but everyone asks you if you might
run for president and I want to ask you
briefly because you come from the
financial World about Nikki Haley's
proposal she's running for president as
we know she says the retirement age
should be lifted I know this is very
controversial President Biden likes to
say that Republicans want to tamper with
Medicare and Social Security but since
those programs are headed toward
insolvency should we have a conversation
about that should people like me in our
30s and 40s prepare for retirement
differently
I believe there's an opportunity for
republicans and Democrats to come
together and have common sense
discussions around this and and these
most challenging policy issues you know
one of the things I found in Virginia is
that when we first spend time agreeing
that there's a problem then we can spend
time coming up with a common sense
bipartisan solution the key here is
problem identification and then getting
together and using common sense to come
up with answers I I think we can do it
in Virginia because we have proven it I
think we should be able to do it at the
federal government level and I just
encourage people to get in a room and
start talking Virginia governor Glenn
youngin thanks for joining us great
thank you so much have a blessed day
[Music]
this is Tommy lahren with your Fox News
commentary coming up
nearly nine months now since people
celebrated or condemned the end of
federal abortion rights overturned by
the Supreme Court many babies will be
saved because of the
time I'm so grateful I've been praying
for this moment for my entire life this
is something that we've been waiting for
we've been fighting for I'm very afraid
for our future how can our nation be
blessed if we just don't care about life
in the in the womb and The Unborn so
yeah we are very stoked that this is
going back to the States and uh it's
only the beginning one of the fights now
is over abortion pills the Walgreens
drugstore chains restricting their sale
in 21 states where Republican Attorneys
General have threatened legal action
even states where abortion still legal
there's been blowback over that policy
from some consumers and Democrats in
Congress and one of the two drugs used
in medical abortions could be banned
Nationwide if a lawsuit filed in federal
court succeeds arguments are being heard
today by a federal judge in Texas the
group is called The Alliance for
Hippocratic medicine it's an
organization that is comprised of
several anti-abortion groups that's the
group actually set up in Amarillo Texas
not long ago Fox News justice
correspondent David spunt there's a
hearing before a Trump appointed federal
judge who could issue a nationwide
injunction on this popular abortion pill
and essentially put it on hold for the
entire country the the drug at issue
here
um is it mifipristone it's been FDA
approved and used in medical abortion
since 2000.
so what's the rationale here
um I can't think of another case where
the court is saying come in and overturn
with the Food and Drug Administration
has done unless unless I just don't know
about it and the Food Drug
Administration is a plaintiff here so
the government's going to be arguing on
on behalf of the Food and Drug
Administration in court in Texas about
this issue as you mentioned it's been on
the market since 2000 there are actually
uh two pills there's mifa Preston is the
first pill it's a two-pill regimen the
second one is called misoprostol and if
the the plaintiffs Prevail here that
would be a a victory not only for them
but it would put into question as you
say 20 years of of
um I don't know if you would call it
precedence but precedence in the actual
Market in the medicine Market because
this has been a legal drug the basis
that this group is suing on they believe
that the FDA rushed this through the the
clinical trials are are not safe they
they say it's not a safe medicine and
they're using uh the idea that the
Supreme Court over turned the right to
an abortion in the Dobbs decision from
last summer essentially overturning Roe
v Wade as another pretext for this but
an important point of that is that the
Supreme Court decision last year last
summer in June actually returned the
issue back to the state so that's why
people are still able to use this
medication and you know adding it a
little bit further I'm at the justice
department right now in the Justice
Department just a couple of months ago
said that the United States Postal
Service is allowed in doj's opinion to
Transport Memphis
across state lines to patients in states
where abortion is illegal I was going to
ask you about that so how does that work
if I'm in Texas I've got to get a doctor
to prescribe it I assume you'd do some
sort of Telehealth with somebody who's
licensed in Texas and then I don't know
what their legal liability is for
prescribing the drug and then the
mailman brings it to you and then you
take it and then I guess it's just on
you to not get caught
that's essentially how it's working and
you know there are more questions than
answers right now and things are a
little bit murky on how this is all
working because you know after the
Supreme Court overturned Roe v Wade
there was a thought by some that okay
abortions automatically illegal nowhere
can it happen in the United States but
as I said as we all know that that's not
the case it's a state-by-state basis
it's a decision up to local state
legislatures so what you raise is
something that people do deal with not
only do they deal with the telemedicine
issue and have something shipped to them
which makes it more convenient but in
some cases women are still growing
across state lines to get this
medication or to have the procedure and
you know according to multiple different
independent organizations that track
these kind of things medical abortions
are actually more prevalent than the
procedure so these two pills mifa
Preston filed by misoprostol
is more common more than half the
abortions are done in this two-pill
regimen than the traditional procedure
at an abortion clinic now my
understanding like we've been saying
there's this two drug protocol in a lot
of countries it's a one drug protocol
using just one of these two drugs and
that on its own singly can induce
miscarriage but with just I guess higher
incidence of side effects than using
both now I guess some abortion providers
are like fine if this happens we'll just
use the one drug
even the lawsuit's successful so I'm not
sure I'm not clear how this leads to
fewer abortions it may just it also may
also lead to more surgical abortions
where those are still legal
exactly and more problems and as you
said more uh symptoms and whatnot so
what the judge his name is Matthew
because Merrick what he's looking at is
specifically mifa Preston now
misoprostol is the drug that you're
talking about that is used in other
countries and according to data in
research misoprostol provides a lot of
nausea and other side effects that if
it's just used on its own I'm not a
medical doctor I'm just talking about
what's been been said in studies what
other countries use what not now the
mifoprestone has been on the market
since 2000 has been used with this
misoprostol you bring up an important
point that if mifa Preston is taken off
or at least put in an injunction which
just means they temporary hold a
temporary stop you know will there be
more usage of only the misoprostol or
the more surgical abortions which means
that women you know some 40 plus million
who are of the you know child bearing
age in the United States would have to
cross state lines to get those
procedures done yeah so even if there's
really a lot I wish I could answer these
questions but there's there's truly so
much that's at stake and it depends on
you know what this judge does I mean he
is the only judge in Amarillo Texas that
is qualified to hear this the only
article 3 judge that's able to hear this
uh the group set up in Amarillo Texas
knowing that they would be able to get
this judge and you know that right there
is already causing more questions and
answers just the fact that you know this
is one judge in Amarillo Texas that
could essentially put this on hold for
the entire country but these groups
these pro-life groups believe they have
a reason to do this and you know they're
pushing forward yeah I mean other than
the fact that he's appointed by
President Trump is there any
indication of how the judge might be
leaning on this well you know it's
interesting you say that I mean not
specifically the issue but an important
point is that last Friday he held a
conference with attorneys and set a
hearing for Wednesday March 15th which
is the hearing date but originally did
not want to announce it to the public
wanted to kind of go below the radar and
ask both parties to keep it under the
radar as a courtesy now this is
typically not what a federal judge would
do schedule and hearing like this in
such a high profile case really in any
case that comes before a federal judge
should be notified should be on the
public document days in advance now the
reasoning potentially for this judge and
we haven't heard from him directly maybe
he'll address it in court in Amarillo is
that there may be protests there may be
safety concerns this is a small judicial
building in Amarillo Texas and you know
there may be concerns that both pro-life
and pro-choice groups will travel to
Texas uh specifically Amarillo the
Panhandle to protest outside which of
course is people's rights on both sides
so there is a little bit of confusion
and a little bit of darkness and and why
the judge originally wanted to keep this
quiet that has since changed it will be
an open hearing uh members of the media
can go inside I'm not going to be inside
members of the public can go inside but
Amarillo Texas I just looked this
morning is six hours from Dallas there
are no direct flights from major cities
into Amarillo Texas so the fact that
it's being made public a day before I
think is probably by Design yeah so if
you want to get your protest on you're
going to be majorly inconvenienced but
I'm sure that there will still there are
still protests going to be happening um
what happens in the short-term medium
term long-term possibly
um if the lawsuit is successful uh like
you said I guess there could be an
injunction or does this just get kicked
up to the next course so if there's an
injunction that would temporarily stop
the distribution of this this drug this
methylpredstone okay meaning that the
actual lawsuit itself that this group
this Hippocratic Alliance Group suing
the FDA would still make its way through
courts right now it's at the district
court level could conceivably go to the
appeals court level and then conceivably
the Supreme Court in Washington where I
am so the injunction just temporarily uh
temporarily stops that it's not a full
on stop and you can bet there will be an
appeal from the United States almost
immediately if this judge does in fact
stop this medication from being
distributed because as we've pointed out
and you've pointed out this medication
is not something that's been on the
market two years five years ten years
but the fall of 2000. covering the
latest battle in the war over abortion
Fox News justice correspondent David
spond David thanks you're very welcome
[Music]
foreign
a Chicago man has filed a class-action
lawsuit against Buffalo Wild Wings on
the grounds that it's so-called boneless
wings are actually closer to chicken
nuggets the suit says Buffalo Wild Wings
advertising of boneless wings is false
and deceptive claiming the company wants
diners to believe the wings have been
deboned when they're actually not wings
at all instead are quote slices of
chicken breast meat deep fried like
wings akin to a chicken nugget which he
says is a cheaper chicken products and
while the discrepancy may seem like
semantics The Man Behind the suit points
to the fact that Buffalo Wild Wings
competitors are careful not to mislabel
their meat chunks he notes that Papa
John's calls the dish chicken poppers
while at Domino's they're labeled
boneless chicken to avoid any confusion
Buffalo Wild Wings took to Twitter to
respond with a series of Saucy tweets
like quote it's true our boneless wings
are all white meat chicken our
hamburgers contain no ham our buffalo
wings are zero percent Buffalo and
crypto is boneless money and decaf is
just boneless coffee as reparations for
the alleged chicken dupe the suit
Demands a jury trial an unspecified
amount of punitive damages lawyer fees
and any other damages as determined by
the judge for the Fox News rundown I'm
Gian jalosi
[Music]
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
I'm Dana Perino join me for season three
of my limited time podcast everything
will be okay based on my best-selling
book of the same name make sure you
subscribe to this series wherever you
download podcasts and leave a rating and
review subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary Tommy Lauren what's
on your mind I'm gonna say something
very bluntly Mexico is not safe I'm not
the only one warning you either Texas
officials have put out a memo to Spring
Breakers don't go to Mexico recent
cartel activity violence and day-to-day
crime and corruption in that country
makes it unsafe for Americans and
especially young people looking to get
drunk and party and I've heard all the
excuses before it's safe in the resort
areas it's safe if you're in a group no
it's not my friend Taylor Meyer was
stabbed to death in Mexico four years
ago in the upscale Resort Town applied
Del Carmen and he was traveling with a
large group for a friend's birthday yes
it is dangerous in American cities but
news flash when you go to a foreign
country and especially a foreign country
with a corrupt government if something
happens to you you are largely on your
own you know what Florida is beautiful
this time of year kiddos you don't need
to risk your life to party in Mexico
over spring break I'm Tommy lahron and
you can watch my show Tommy learn as
Fearless outkick.com
[Music]
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
I'm Emily compagno and this is the fox
True Crime podcast bringing you closer
to the story than you ever thought
possible subscribe at foxnewspodcast.com
or wherever you download podcasts these
are the stories that keep you up at
night
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes